wir haben sorgen dass der impfstoff
nicht so richtig hilft gegen diese neue
variante wie schätzen sie das sein wie
groß müssen uns unsere sorgen dass sein
also die beobachtung der veränderung die
die variante in dem labor
verursachte mit den serien die dort
getestet wird von verschiedenen menschen
die zweimal geimpft wurden die flächen
drei mal infiziert also die sorge hat
man man darf nicht vergessen wir den ja
nur einen kleinen ausschnitt aus den
möglichkeiten die der körper hat
immunologisch dieses virus abzuwehren
und die daten aus deutschland bestätigen
das was man in südafrika anderen denn da
gesehen hat dass die erste das erste
bollwerk der immunantwort diese
antikörper ja sehr spezifisch sind das
nikon bei uns nicht so gut erkennen die
datenlage ist noch nicht so ganz gut
weil man noch wer wenig
testsiegern bis jetzt untersuchungen
konnte aber diese zweite und dritte
abwehrreihe dieses weitere bollwerk
diese makrophagen und fakten also diese
fresszellen die da ja noch dahinter
stehen in der immunantwort und das
dritte bollwerk diese kinder zählen die
sind ja auch noch da die sind nicht
durch spezifische immunantwort wie diese
antikörper die auf den schleimhäuten der
der lage des rachens existieren und der
vortags wieder abfallen also die
killerzellen die
fresszellen die hat man natürlich mit
dem test nicht versucht zu erkennen das
geht eigentlich mit diesem test nicht
dass mit weiteren untersucht also man
darf nicht glauben dass diese daten die
jetzt vorliegen der beweis dafür denn
dass die impfstoffe
ausgeschaltet sind oder gar nicht mehr
funktionieren sondern es ist vielleicht
eine absenkung der wirksamkeit zu sehen
aber die das boostern jetzt kann diese
leichten rückgang auch wieder abpuffern
weil also auch die antikörper
vielmehr wieder vorhanden sind wie
können dann diese nicole bios dann auch
weiß sie an mich in der masse dann
wieder agieren doch noch abfangen und
dann die erste und dritte werk das die
monat los
dass die impfung generiert sind ja noch
da also die informiert wird weiter der
wichtigste pfeiler der reduktion der
auswirkung der partie bleiben also dass
boost dann wird damit noch wichtiger als
es eh schon ist wie schätzen sie
überhaupt die gefährlichkeit dieser
neuen variante ein man hat fast das
gefühl jetzt kommt schon wieder was um
die ecke wann kommt das nächste um die
ecke wie betrachten sie diese
entwicklung
ja weil ich ihnen garantieren kann ist
dass nikon die nächste variante kommt
dann wieder eine und noch eine und
erinnern sie sich vielleicht an dass die
linguistik und das vokabular als eltern
gekommen ist dann ging es ja um turbo
virus da ging es um neue pandemie und
dann waren die kinder besonders
betroffenen stärker krankheitsverläufe
höhere übertragungsfähigkeit und dann
kann man doch relativ entspannter sommer
und dann ist das eingetreten was wir
gesagt haben im winter nehmen die
atemwegserkrankung tour noch die neue
variante wird hier nichts dramatisch
ändern es ist natürlich nicht
wünschenswert dass jetzt eine neue folge
kommt aber es ist auch nicht zu
verhindern wir müssen uns darauf
einstellen die industrie arbeitet
bereits an dem der aktualisierung der
jetzigen impfstoffe das braucht keine
zeit zum glück nur drei bis vier monate
wenn man noch die traditionellen
impfstoffe ausschließlich hätte dann
würden wir ganz locker von sechs bis 18
monaten sprechen bevor wir neue
impfstoffe zur verfügung stehen würden
mit den existierenden
impfstoffe wurden m rna aus den anderen
eu-staaten haben wir ganz tolle
werkzeuge in der hand die auswirkungen
der pandemie zu reduzieren wir wissen
jetzt dass das virus sich der leichten
übertragen lässt weltweit wir wissen
dass die
impf antwort unter umständen das
schwächer ausfällt wir wissen bereits
dass die und wir wissen es gibt hinweise
darauf dass vielleicht der
erkrankungsverlauf etwas milder sein
könnte aber ich kann ihnen garantieren
dass märz wird es keinen neuen impfstoff
geben wir müssen mit dem auskommen was
wir haben das ist auch gut die ersten
ergebnisse auch aus frankfurt aus
anderen ländern sind hinweise darauf
dass es noch leicht abgeschwächten
immunantwort geben wird aber wie groß
diese abschwächung werden wir in zwei
bis drei wochen wissen wenn die daten
aus den kliniken da sind wenn man genau
sehen kann ob wie geimpfte auf die
infektion reagieren hier geht was wir
hier sehen sind ja laborbefunde die
hinweise dafür gegeben aber die
sogenannten real wird der daten also die
aus den krankenstationen kommen die aus
südafrika dann und geliefert werden die
wir dann die tatsächliche antwort bieten
wie wie besorgte tatsächlich sein müssen
danke für die erklärung professor klaus
stöhr also ganz klar boostern auf jeden
fall selbst wenn die impfung etwas
schwächer wird gegen diese neue omikron
variante als gegen die bisherigen danke
für diese erklärung und interessant auch
dass er sagt es werden auf jeden fall
immer neue varianten kommen denn das ist
ja das was die politik und sagt ob
ballack schon wieder eine neue variante
das wussten wir gar nicht da müssen wir
jetzt wieder nachschärfen usw die
überraschung die kann sich die politik
ab jetzt knicken der professor klaus
stöhr sagt nee nee das wird nicht die
letzte variante sein da kommen leider
leider immer immer neu